hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive
and in the next half hour we'll see
what's making the headlines with the
economics correspondent at the spectator
kate andrews
and the deputy online editor for the new
statesman rachel kunliff thanks
both of you very much for joining us uh
let's see what's on the front of some of
those newspapers
the prime minister is urging everyone to
get a covered vaccine over fears
the spread of the indian variant of the
virus is being fueled by those who've
refused the jab
that is the front of the telegraph boris
johnson's words are also on the front of
the express
who says the relaxation of the rules
should be met with a heavy
dose of caution the sun celebrates both
the success of the vaccines
and against the variant and the return
of indoor drinking from tomorrow
don't blow at britain says the mail
health experts have told the guardian
that people should ignore the easing of
restrictions and continue to socialize
outside foreign travel plans are in
chaos according to the times after
health secretary matt hancock said
britons should not travel to amber list
countries
the star says britain's plan to savour
plays and work of art
as lockdown restrictions ease
metro claims to be britain's biggest
national weekday newspaper again now
that lockdown
is being lifted and the financial times
leads with news of a potential deal by
the american firm at t
to combine warner media with discovery a
move that could challenge
netflix dominance in the streaming arena
well let's get more on those papers with
kate andrews and rachel kunliff
and kate we're going to kick off with
you and it's on the front of most of the
front pages the
the re-easing of restrictions tomorrow
lots of people looking forward to it it
seems
yes it's on nearly every front page the
next step in the prime minister's road
map has gotten the green light in
england this means that
restrictions on indoor and outdoor
socializing are
easing up to 30 can meet outside six
people or two households and doors
as well as indoor hospitality reopening
hotels cinemas theaters and the like
um in scotland and wales across the uk
uh the
the rules are slightly different wales
is moving slower on indoor socializing
for example but they are moving down to
alert level two so tomorrow is a big
easing day
across the uk many will be looking
forward to it but also an important
reminder that this is by no means
back to normal and hospitality is
already being very loud about the fact
that if we can't get to the 21st of june
and essentially have all of these
restrictions left
they simply won't be able to turn a
profit and so you know wonderful to be
able to host people inside for a cup of
tea now outside of your bubble
but by no means back to where we were
pre-pandemic
rachel do you think that we will all be
eager to get out because
once we could socialize outside
everybody was seemed very keen to do
that we saw a lot of
footage of of some of the pubs in the
center of london being really really
busy outside
um but the weather hasn't been great
over the last few weeks
do you think we've all slightly fallen
out of love with socializing a little
bit
i think reentry anxiety as it's called
is definitely a real thing i think
we've been living under very very
strange conditions for the last year
and i do think that people's social
circles or sense of socialization
has um contracted somewhat certainly i i
think about my social life
two years ago and the number of people i
was seeing and the amount i was doing
and it just seems
exhausting now i can manage sort of one
one one piece of socializing one trip to
a bar or restaurant a week now
um i'm hoping that as people start to
feel a bit more secure
and as um the restrictions ease and we
sort of slide back into normality
some of that will come back although as
kate said it's it's it's not it's far
from normal it's as normal
as it was over the summer um but still
uh many of the the the live events or or
big crowds
that's not coming back certainly not
until the end of june and i do think
that people's
feeling about uh about about those large
mass events
there probably will be some residual
insecurity and some residual
nervousness and anxiety there as i think
it's totally natural but what i'm really
looking forward to
this week we focus a lot on hospitality
is the fact that for the first time
in basically six months it's not illegal
to go around to somebody's house
for a cup of tea and those home settings
particularly for families and
for for small groups of friends that i
think is something that's really
important and that is where
a lot of people will have felt the lack
of socialization
the most over this over the winter yeah
it is interesting isn't it kate that the
the sun is focusing on shots but but a
lot of a lot of papers over the last
couple days been focusing on hugs
and that does seem to be that human
contact seems to be
one of the things that has been missed
the most during this lockdown
well certainly it's it's different for
for everybody of course what they
prioritize and
uh the sun's pun there which is also
picked up in the daily telegraph in a
slightly more serious tone is that we're
talking about two different kinds of
shots not just the kinds you might take
at a bar but the fact that the prime
minister
is now putting the emphasis on the jabs
to get us through this crisis and we
should note this is a big
change in tone from the prime minister
and his officials there was a real
attempt just weeks ago
to try to get people to continue to obey
all the lockdown rules to emphasize that
the jabs weren't 100 effective uh he was
insistent that two fully jab people
still couldn't meet indoors and we
really saw a shift last friday in the
press conference now they're saying
you know please get your jab we need to
prioritize getting vaccines because that
is the way out
and of course that is the right message
vaccines work
and that is why we are now moving to
this next step where we can all take
more
personal choice and responsibility about
who we hug who we're near who we're
inside with
who we're still slightly more careful
around because the most vulnerable and
the elderly now in this country have
been offered their first job indeed
millions have had their second job we
are in a much safer place
than we ever were last year coming in
and out of lockdowns
and that's what's enabled this next step
so that we can all have a little more
say in decision and
and do our own risk assessment when we
decide who we see and how we see
them and and rachel the guardian's front
page
it's headline britain's open up but
experts want public to stick to meeting
outdoors
um you know it's fair enough if it's a
nice day but
you know it will be nice to be able to
shelter won't it
well this is exactly what kate was
saying and i think she's absolutely
right that if you want more people to
take
the vaccine you want vaccine rates to be
as high as possible you have to push the
message
that vaccines work and just talk about
how miraculous
they are and and uh also making the
front pages
in some of those that we've already
discussed is the fact that there's been
so much concern over the
the indian variant which it looks like
is significantly
uh more transmissible than other strains
however the existing vaccines we have
work against us and protect people
against that and that's really important
and the messaging from the government
over the past few months that yes get
vaccinated but just be very careful just
in case because
it doesn't give you as much protection
as you think it does i think may have
done
some real damage to to vaccine uptake
and now i think that the change in tone
saying this is this is what you need to
do in order to protect yourself and
protect others
um is really valuable whereas um the
these warnings from scientists in the
guardian
which are very valid firstly talking
about uh how transmission is much lower
outdoors which we know that it is
and obviously as you say if it's a sunny
day i think people may feel that it is
less less of a risk and indeed
more pleasant to continue socializing
outside but you have to balance that
risk of a scientific message with a very
positive message
that there is a step you can take in
order to reduce
your risk and the risk of others and
that is getting vaccinated and
separating those two messages
and focusing on the pro-vaccine one is i
think the way forward if you want to
make sure that the people who have been
reluctant to get vaccinated so far
really do you see the benefits
and kate look we look at the telegraph
again that same message play your part
to beat the variant the pm urges the
public
do you think the possibility of going
away on summer holiday might
might sharpen the minds and the focus of
people who were a little bit ambivalent
towards having vaccines before now
well look i i think a lot can help sway
hearts and minds you know your neighbors
and friends around you getting
vaccinated and having positive
experiences
um you know thinking about the
opportunity to be safe as we had indoors
as you might get on a plane
all of that's hopefully encouraging
people to get the vaccine but let's not
take for granted that britain continues
to pull as one of the top countries in
the world that's keen to get
its vaccine you know you have people who
are absolutely desperate
to get it who are just waiting to get
their texts that's all really positive
now we need those education campaigns
to help encourage people who are still
hesitant about it about the real
great reasons why you might get your
vaccine at the moment those in bolton
who are in hospital
um suffering with the indian variant the
vast majority of them did have the
opportunity to get the vaccine in
and turned it down and we that's very
sad we want to avoid situations like
that as
as much as we can um but overall there
is huge desire for uptake and
this is really encouraging for the uk
it's the reason that we're able to keep
taking the steps that we are to
reopening because the vast vast majority
of vulnerable and elderly
are now jabbed and as i said before it's
very different set of circumstances now
um and whilst i i do appreciate that you
know if you want to be extremely
cautious
uh it is certainly the case that you're
much less likely to spread this virus
outdoors which is what the
scientists and professors on the front
page of the guardian are talking about
but there have been
serious tradeoffs to not being able to
have indoor economic and socializing
activity and now it's up to the
individual
to decide if that trade-off is worth it
anymore kate
and rachel we're going to take a short
break coming up
palestinian activists slurs condemned
that is on the front page of the
telegraph
we call this you know a smartphone but
actually using it as a phone is just a
small proportion of what we do with it
so our argument is we need to understand
this as something
bigger than that and uh we start by
saying you know
think of it more as a place within which
you live i mean you spend so much
time there you're sort of organizing
your life there
socializing with people and that sounds
positive but one of the consequences of
that
is that um you might think you know the
person
next door to you when you're sort of
having a meal together is
with you um but it's just so easy
to take this out for your pocket and
suddenly
they've gone home they've gone to that
smartphone home
um and they're completely oblivious to
you being next to them
this is something that may actually vary
from country to country you're
absolutely right
that i was thinking in the uk it's all
going to be
older people saying you know these
younger people they were supposed to be
with me
and they're spending all their time on
the smartphone now actually uh
the researcher in in shanghai found that
sometimes it was the other way around
um because older people in china they
they associate with the kind of
national project of being in the the
vanguard of i.t
and they have perhaps a more positive
association than
with the phones and you'll sometimes see
that it's you know the young people
going with them to a restaurant and
saying you know grandma
um i thought we were taking you out for
a nice meal and how come you're spending
all your time on the smartphone but what
are they actually
doing on their smartphones and much of
the time
you know they're on whatsapp perhaps the
most important of apps
to us these days or um you know they're
with other people so it's not
necessarily an
anti-social device it may be rude to the
person next to you
but actually they may be talking to
somebody in a different country
or somebody who you know needs their
attention and their care an elderly
parent
um so the social life that is being now
created through the smartphone can often
be enormously positive
and goes beyond what was possible before
and i think again you're right
that if there's one period when that's
become really clear to us
it's been over the last year because you
know everyone says
you know we miss the hugs we miss the
face to face but then they say
you know what if we'd spaced the last
year without things like the smartphone
it's it's too horrible even to imagine
hello my name is inna braverman and i'm
the founder and ceo of eco-wave power
i believe that wave power which can
produce
twice the amount of electricity that the
world produces now
is definitely a great cause
[Music]
i grew up seeing the impacts of climate
change firsthand
having to be afraid of drowning in my
own bedroom and
sometimes waking up in the middle of the
night with flood water in my room
we needed an organization that
specifically talked about the climate
and so me and my friends we
decided to put up youth advocates for
climate action philippines i had to join
the fight
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now kate andrews and
rachel cunliffe and we're
returning for daily telegraph for the
story we've been covering this evening
here on sky news this is a
a bunch of people in cars in london
driving uh through
st john's wood and shouting
awful statements um rachel it's it's
rightly made the papers but we
understand that there have been some
arrests this evening as well
there have been some arrests this is
quite an emotional one for me to discuss
because it's about 15 minutes away from
where i live and it referred to the
shouts referred to
raping jewish girls so that
unfortunately
includes me in that and it has um really
sent shockwaves through the jewish
community the the condemnation from the
prime minister and other political
leaders
has been swift and as you say people
have uh been
arrested for this but this this shift in
the
uh the way that we've been talking about
the middle east and what's going on in
israel and and palestine as an as an
issue that somehow is
the responsibility of jews here in the
uk
is something that is incredibly damaging
and and disturbing
because there is a huge huge range of
opinion among the jewish community in
the uk the vast majority of whom
absolutely are appalled at what is going
on in in gaza
and israel and many of whom actively
oppose
netanyahu and the behavior of the
israeli government
but it is this kind of rhetoric that
blames what is going on in a country
very very far away on the jewish
community here
are people who have absolutely nothing
to do with it that is going to cement in
the minds
of many jews there really does need to
be a jewish state because
we can be made to feel very unsafe in
our own country for something that has
absolutely nothing to do with us
and kate the ft's front page is about
that the un security council uh
as well and and it's condemned the
violence and says that it hopes that
both sides
can reach a resolution but the un
doesn't really have a brilliant record
of actually achieving a great deal in
that part of the world does it there's
there's always lots of words uh and lots
of strong sentiments but very little
action
well exactly although this week i i do
think that
a big story is going to be the ramping
up of international efforts to try to
stop what is
one of the worst conflicts we've seen
between israel and palestine for
some years now it doesn't look like it's
winding down we have nearly 200 deaths
in gaza we have at least 10 in israel uh
many innocent
uh people dying and and so i do think
you're going to see a ramp up from the
international community
just to echoes echo rachel's words
though and
very sadly here in the uk where we have
seen too many instances of anti-semitism
in recent years
um these so-called activists um you know
are
don't need um any kind of excuse their
main goal here is just to
promote anti-semitic rhetoric and it's
awful and disgusting
and uh something that has been condemned
across the board today and it's positive
to see but the fact that it happens in
the first place
and the fact that the jewish community
has to live with this in the uk in 2021
is
is truly a disgrace um and there's no
excuse for it so thank goodness
action is going to be taken and and
hopefully uh swiftly as well but
really sad scenes in north london today
and rachel i'm sorry it happened so
close to your home